good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy wednesday
hope everyone's having an amazing home
day
let's get the streis brothers out to
celebrate hump day we have our pillows
the streisbros are here in spirit
they're actually extremely busy today
packing for an amazing weekend out east
they are so excited because they're such
hamptons girlies
morass and strassen brass and strassen
brats and strats and brats and strats
and rats and strats and rising strides
you know bryson streisand is kind of
the song that never ends i was just
thinking that when do you end it the
thing about me is like when i learned
that song i never unlearned it and i
will never you i will be singing that
song well into my nineties this is the
people who know that song okay i think
everybody knows that song i think
everyone is really hoping that you don't
start it because i don't think there's a
more annoying song or anything out there
and i really think it'll
be harmful for your brand if you start
singing that song i just feel like there
might be people who don't know what song
i'm talking about i'll sing it once okay
no no no i personally like i'm
boycotting this this is the song that
never ends it just goes on and on my
friend
some people started singing it not
knowing what it was but they'll continue
singing it forever just because this is
the song that and then it goes on and on
and on and don't lie i saw your shoulder
shaking a little that song has a way
with
words
i can't talk about this song like
i just i hate it so much oh my god you
did a nice rendition i'll give that to
you but
like i need to move on from this song i
i think i have trauma why because it's
so annoying it's gorgeous
like for me the concept of a song that
doesn't end heaven let us know what you
think pro or con yeah there everyone's
going to be con but that's because they
don't know anything they don't know [ __ ]
about [ __ ]
as you would say but in the swear jar no
[ __ ] that's your thing you owe me like
a dollar twenty-five okay no i owe baby
to baby a dollar twenty-five i'll send
it don't worry i'll make sure the money
gets there oh sure she's gonna run a
ponzi scheme through my swear jar buy a
purse
um
today is wednesday which means a
multitude of things the first it means
the first thing it means is that our
live show breaking bread our spotify
original has a new episode coming out
tonight we will be live from 7 p.m
eastern time to 8 pm eastern time you
can listen live on the spotify app or if
you want to download the spotify live
app make a username join the chat get
pulled on stage that'll be really fun it
also means that we have dear toasters
today which i'm super excited about
because i read through them and the last
one is truly a doozy like wow i don't
know if we're gonna be able to give
proper guidance because it's truly a
conundrum i think you need to make that
the first one because sometimes by the
third one i'm still thinking about the
first two and i can't wrap my head
around that's just a little secret a
trick of the trade
done wow you're so
efficient what's the word accommodating
it's a pleasure um today's episode is
also really special because at the end
of the podcast we have an interview with
jill zarin talking real housewives
ultimate girls trip the video's also on
youtube so check that out and just sit
back relax and enjoy the power of the
toast you know by the time you're done
listening to this episode it's basically
july 4th weekend for you guys 100 would
you say that we have a great show for
them today um do you want me to say that
like are you ready to start no no i feel
like there's so much more to be said
actually i literally every day it's like
when we do the show but just my days in
general like when i'm done with the day
i never think about it again like i
don't know what i did yesterday every
day i like sit here i'm like what did i
do that i wanted to share idk you know i
think that's part of survival like
leaving things in the past yeah but
yesterday we did record the redheads
episode about girls with bright futures
and claudia joined i did jackie we were
facetiming and she was like i'm gonna go
record the redheads like she was sitting
at her desk with her microphone and i'm
like
should i make this about me and i
definitely did you know i think that
four people is the most amount of people
you really can and should have on a
podcast
who's no wallflower right like
definitely i think dana was you know
most affected by my presence because she
probably gets like sidelined most of the
time because she's like not shy but
she's not as like loud as everyone else
um
i definitely think it was a really fun
thing that like i shouldn't do again
because it is too many people yeah it
was but we had a really good time and
you know one more opinion and claudia
actually took a stance that no one else
had so i'm glad you added value to the
conversation yeah justice for kelly
justice for kelly also what's crazy is
that this is already my sixth podcast
i'm doing this week and it's only
wednesday morning well that's insane
isn't that insane to do one more
afternoon for you because you did
redheads yes
yeah by tonight it'll be seven no no
tonight we have seven and eight
seven we're recording after this for
repeating and then breaking bread and
breaking bread is eight eight podcasts
in three days podcast podcast podcast
they never sleep we're giving you
content all weekend you guys so you if
you're on a trip in a share house with
people that you don't know because
you're with your partner's friends like
listen to the toast we're here for you
that's why like whenever i see like any
people i follow have podcasts and most
podcasts are weekly and they're like oh
i have to actually do it tomorrow like
what
like if they're always saying i'm gonna
do it on monday it's like actually i'm
gonna come out on tuesday this week what
were you doing
and that's not to say like recording a
60-minute podcast isn't a lot of work it
is but like literally what are you doing
when a person has seven days and they
need an eighth day yeah and like you're
you're always doing people always are
like i'm gonna do every monday every
monday but more often than not they're
like actually this week i'm gonna do
tuesday yeah it's like girly we're doing
a podcast in three days but then again
that's why we're titans in our industry
right that's why we're number five on
the comedy charts right now and we have
two episodes in the top ten yes i saw
that this morning i actually
screenshotted it and i was like can i
post it to my story because i was
feeling
proud as you should [ __ ] as you should
i think i will i like never brag on
myself unless it's like i'm reposting
someone else you know unless someone
else is doing it for you right but
like even the number two on spotify
thing i didn't see until someone put in
toast after dark though i do look at the
charts i just i never even thought we're
never on the spotify charts ever because
like most people listen on apple
podcasts um so i don't even go there
because it's a little depressing and it
feels like we're being relevant yeah
yeah irrelevant girlies no but we're
just irrelevant yeah no but and that's
you know there is comfort in being
irrelevant 100
so you know i think part of this job is
like it comes in waves like a lot of
people are talking about you and then
like there's a lull and when you're in a
lull you're like oh my god like my life
is over like i'm at least for me like
that's how i feel i'm like i'm depressed
no one's talking about me um and then
like a peek will come and even if people
are talking about you it's always going
to be good and bad of course so then i'm
in a peak and i'm like [ __ ] like i would
long for the days of being irrelevant
right where i write like just quiet out
the noise right that's just like the
mental health roller coaster of being a
podcaster and an influencer and yeah we
speak on behalf of influencers like
everyone
voice for the influencers so it's
actually so funny i said after monday's
episode i got so many messages from
influencers like thanking me for my
tirade justice for influencers yesterday
i got so many messages from tuesday's
episode being like why do i feel like
the influencer you were talking about
who you like hate follow is me i'm like
no oh really yeah i'm like really if i
follow you like i love you i don't
follow people i hate right can you tell
us like who thought it was them just
some talkers some like people like that
i'm friends with i think they were like
joking but like oh they were i think
they were messaging me to find out who
the influencer was but i will take the
secret to my grave i love that for you
to my grave
as will i i know steel trap and that's
what's so important about being in
business with your sister yeah because
if you were just like my friend you
wouldn't really like you would you would
keep the secret like if someone pressed
you and like you were drinking like you
would say it but you're bound by blood
mm-hmm by that secret and i don't have
it i don't drink right and i don't have
a lot of secrets do you
no
no i think like secrets
for one it's tough to have it's
important to have like personal like
things
thoughts whatever but
it's like they say secrets keep you sick
and if you can talk about something like
it already ends the burden that's true
so that's my philosophy i like that and
i try to like if there's something going
on that's maybe a secret like i
definitely tell like you yeah yeah yeah
like mom and like our family yeah yeah i
don't have secrets from like my close
close circle yeah you don't you don't no
i don't i'm really like an open book i
should probably keep more secrets close
it up close your legs to married man
close my book
to married men um well we have a great
show
and i'm ready to start if you are i
guess so
how's harry
he's good thank you for asking he's just
a sweet little nugget dreaming of auntie
dreaming of auntie you know he really
loves you so much you know what i'm
dreaming of like spending like four days
uninterrupted in the same house as harry
like that is gonna be like so special
when he like got all of these clothes
for the fourth of july he's such a
patriot like he loves his country and
he's really gonna be in theme all week
and it's gonna be really special
you guys like i cannot wait and i've
spent like uninterrupted
time not to like pit niece against
nephew like my only experience here i go
but my only experience like with
children is of course michaela like my
first everything was with michaela um
and it was amazing never forget your
first you never forget your first but
michaela like did and does hate me with
like a deep fiery passion and i get it
like i'm super annoying like and i guess
she doesn't want to be like entertained
all the time like she'd rather hang out
with her friends or like watch tv or
play with your toys um but there's
something about harry that he is like
obsessed with my annoying energy
and to have that energy received is so
fulfilling like i really can't put into
words like what that's like like harry
would love the song that never ends
done he would love it he's like it never
ends sign me sign me up and harry like i
swear like i always sing to children
because that's like my talent um
most kids like michaela would just like
look the other way harry
eye contact smile giggle thinks it's the
best thing that he's obviously like a
true feeling
i think he's gonna grow up to be a
talent agent like he sees talent he
knows what's good that's so true we
should get a job also be like a film
critic like ebert and roper oh my god i
could totally see him on the back of
taxi tv sandy canyon with the eyewitness
news movie minute but he would just
think everything was so amazing no no
what are you trying to say no like he
loves everything he loves entertainment
no i think if someone was singing poorly
he wouldn't smile and like why i sing
and he loves it but you're his mom like
he heard you he heard your voice in
utero like he knows you that's true me
actually you know somebody did say
something in our toast after dark
patreon group that i thought was really
poignant
because we were talking maybe on a
patreon just about how like obviously
i'm harry's favorite auntie truly by
default because i spend the most time
with him um but we definitely have this
connection and someone was like you know
you sat here for nine months pregnant
sitting with me for an hour every day i
talk like 75 percent of the time like
harry definitely knows my voice and i
saw that then when he came out of the
womb he was like oh that's that [ __ ]
that's my [ __ ] yeah it's like morning
toast gurley i like that theory me too
and i think it's totally possible i
think so too
makes you think makes you think maybe i
gotta go like sing around all the
pregnant people i know just when their
babies come out we have a connection
they find favor yes
definitely you know those machines that
like you put like two things on the
belly and then there's wires connected
to a microphone yeah first of all when
i'm pregnant i will be purchasing one of
those um and second of all i'm gonna
purchase one now like to go around to
all the pregnant people i know and just
like serenade their children love that
for you
you're welcome did you start a business
i just realized i haven't eaten a thing
like all day my stomach was making crazy
noises all day it's not 4 p.m it's
literally 9 a.m okay well when you wake
up early it's like late in the day some
of my fiber one bar no because we're
doing so well on the charts and i don't
want to ruin things yeah no no chewing
starve yeah that's fine yeah um true
devon now i feel ready to dive in so
without further
do
where are you
come back to the toe do it again
where are you
why are you changing the melody why
can't i improv it's only okay when you
do it yes
where are you come back to your auntie
come back to yad aunty
come back to y'all welcome
come back to brass and stress
we need to release an ep like of all the
toast jingles and by the way like that
would be an amazing album for kids okay
so let's say how many songs maybe you
need like six to eight okay to be on an
ep bryce is tristan obviously
dora the explorer perfect angel dora
love of my life dora sweet kisses dora
crunchy lipstora swedish fur dora that's
actually the song that never ends oh
that is okay um final story
yes
um wait we have more uh
well we have some other ones just on the
toast
oh snitch on the toes but i'm bum
you were singing um like we have some
personal songs that we sing i don't know
if we would include those like when
you're saying like roxanne lil harry
will harry that's such a good song so we
can maybe add that like in the bonus
patreon yeah oh welcome to the morning
toast welcome welcome welcome welcome
welcome welcome welcome welcome welcome
welcome to the morning toast we probably
have to get like copyright like
licensing for that from
she's the man yeah but there's one other
song oh and then also sometimes what was
the new brightest one
brass and strats and brass and straws no
there was one member
you got it oh first of all bruno bernard
yeah but there was the one
bruno de bruyne no
um you know who we need to tap for this
first of all like we actually like if we
do it like we need serious like people
and you know who so you know jackie
schimel's husband's in
studio number jackie schumer's husband
a brain the
is like a big music producer you were
trying like one of my favorite one
direction songs she told me once and
whenever she does anything like
musically like he does it for her like
in their office like we need that we do
like my god if ben could just like work
in music we need to go to the studio lay
down some tracks yeah and like upload
that we also are in a studio yeah no but
this is not the right as someone who's
recorded to um flop songs you need like
a real studio and if anyone out here is
like friendly with or you yourselves are
like a music producer being like dude i
don't want like a producer i need
everyone to do the whole thing you know
lay the tracks we can write the lyrics
and of course perform them but like yeah
i think if we came out with like a
children's ep it would be so popular
agreed and now that we're saying this
like people are going to come out of the
woodwork with songs that we have like we
also have i just took like for um
dna test turns out i'm a hundred percent
russian oh yeah when i'm fleeing
countries yeah i've got heart problems
that's a puppy in me bling bling then i
solve them that's a doctor in me should
have had a bad tigs just a little we'll
work on it yeah well yeah they'll be
like the wrap this is kids box what is
the ep gonna be called
toast tunes oh my god [ __ ] i was
literally gonna say that this it's just
writing itself
okay we need we're always like saying
things we're gonna do and never do them
literally kids pop it should be called
toe spot and the thing is like it's fun
for all ages
moms and kids alike kid tested mother
approved i think people are going to
love this yeah we just have to like do
it yeah
wow i'd love that for us yeah me too and
we have a relationship with spotify so
they have to put on the new releases
page oh music friday obviously bryce and
charlton on new music friday and i won't
settle for anything left for every
friday in perpetuity yeah cause it's
strategy
gotta get down on strategy
very good okay now without further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
today's episode is brought to you by
peloton peloton has a team of
world-class instructors ready to
motivate you 24 7. peloton instructors
are highly trained fitness pros who
motivate you through every workout
whether you're a regular mom at the gym
or someone who is new and getting back
into working out whatever your fitness
level is peloton instructors don't just
teach they motivate they have thousands
of live and on-demand classes so you can
keep it fresh always from cycling and
strength training to yoga and running
experiment with new types of movement
judgment-free at a level and pace that
feels good for you um jackie i know you
are a peloton girly tell everyone your
username if they want to follow like the
pillow toasters i get so many messages
asking for my username i should make it
a highlight but i don't my username is
jackieoww and i've done a ton of running
classes boot camp
cycling and i do really good class
curation i'm not going to lie and then i
just go into my class history and redo
the classes i've already done and i'm
like why does this instructor always
talk about how she used to work in
banking and it's like because i'm
listening to the same class yeah over
and over again but peloton has thousands
of classes they have arm weights yoga
they have literally any type of workout
that you would want to do i love peloton
this ad is really just like calling me
out though because you know it's been a
minute since i got on my bike you are
allowed i'm a peloton girly through and
through we're we have the pella toaster
community it's a facebook group we do
rides together at like certain times of
day it's so much fun everyone high-fives
one another like if you've been on the
fence about getting a peloton
this is your sign hop the fence right
now is the perfect time to try out
peloton because the peloton bike plus is
now 500 less and it's the best price yet
includes free delivery and setup
and there are more game changing prices
available on the original peloton bike
and the peloton tread so visit
onepeleton.com to learn more
great thank you so much our first story
a little justice news but it's lacking
injustice as well okay galen maxwell the
accomplice to jeffrey epstein has been
sentenced to 20 years in prison for sex
trafficking by
peace out what's the injustice the
injustice is that she's sentenced for
says trafficking but who was she
trafficking to right like how can you be
like sentenced for a crime of like you
know helping facilitate sex trafficking
and rape and abuse but who were your
abusers and the rapist yeah no i think
there's something like that feels
unfulfilling about this colleen maxwell
story like we've been so focused on it
and now that we got the verdict it's
like that's great no but one team not
she's the one person who went down like
it's so bizarre but like how can you
be like on a solo mission of sex
trafficking like was she the one doing
like trafficking them for herself well
maybe she didn't sing for her supper and
that's why she got a heavy sentence like
if she had given names she probably
could have gotten like four or five
years no uh
i don't know if it's that or it's just
like the media covering up like these
big wigs no it would have worked it
would have come out it would have come
out why her trial was like no if if she
had said it wasn't in the trial and then
those people would be prosecuted
we would know if she said any names
and her sentence would be much less i
don't think it was because she's a good
friend i think i think she's a good
friend i think probably like her family
will be taking care of like something
you know
yeah
it's just it's like sometimes i hate to
sound like a conspiracy theorist but
when it comes to galen and jeffrey like
there's no way you can't be a conspiracy
there is like it's not conspiracy this
is straight facts she did this whole sex
trafficking ring who was on the plane
who was at the island like
those people are
right you need to go down like even the
what's his name prince andrews yeah like
where's the justice that's so true no it
feels incomplete this story and while we
love queen fellaini it feels like like
theater you know it's like here
performative yeah like this person it's
over done with clay disclosed justice
has been served and it's like but what
about the whole ring yeah this was a
major operation that's really what about
the fact that jeffrey epstein didn't
kill himself like what about all that i
know and i
i know we've all moved on like from that
time period where like literally ever
the word out of everyone's mouth was
jeffrey epstein didn't kill himself on
but we need to get back to that because
like literally he didn't kill himself
question mark yeah question mark so
every time like the story resurfaces
they could be telling me that claim
maxwell will be paying for the rest of
her life for what she did but it's like
it's just not enough and i just want to
say if colleen maxwell turns up quote
unquote dead in prison meaning she like
fled the country and is living the life
of riley in like antarctica um
i will have questions antarctica is
beautiful this time of year and it's
really the place where you go to live
the life of riley well it has to be one
of those countries that doesn't have
extradition right is that the word yes
like where a cr a criminal can live and
they don't have to send them back to the
states yes but that would mean that like
we know that that's where they are yeah
you know i think if if she fled it
wouldn't be like send her like if she
did protect the most powerful people in
the world like in exchange they could
get her out of prison into a safe house
like she could live in a palace in the
middle of nowhere yeah by the sea by the
sea yes sounds nice
so they could rebuy the island for her
and she can go live there
it's on sale literally so delaney from
the bottom of my toes to the top of my
[ __ ] scalp [ __ ] you is that a
tick-tock sound yeah tenemojo gotta get
tana on the podcast got to there's like
a couple people who i just feel like if
we say their names like we'll get them
on i but like people i really do want to
interview tana monsieur being one of
them yeah so many questions i've become
such a big fan of hers over the years so
funny and like i don't really watch her
content or anything but like i do like
her and i do think like as a big time
loser move i did like slide into her dms
recently and just like respond to one of
her stories like lol huh you know maybe
it made you la ha-ha it did that's why
i'm a genuine person i sometimes do that
to people because like you should know
that i that it was low haha yeah when
someone like reached out to me and it
was like lol and it's like you know
fellow influencer i'm like i made you
laugh yeah no and then if like i i
message someone who i've never spoken to
before and i see that they've messaged
me previously like responding to a story
or something i'm like oh my god we are
friends right did she follow you tim no
um
yeah so we gotta work on that that was
sad yeah yeah
um are you ready for our next story i am
some very scary news travis barker was
rushed to the hospital in an ambulance
with courtney by his side on tuesday
afternoon travis barker was rushed to
the hospital the drummer was
photographed lying on a stretcher
outside cedar sinai medical center in la
while the kardashian star followed on
foot the musician was seen being wheeled
out of the ambulance while holding his
right hand up which showed his
unmistakable skull tattoo
courtney for her part was seen only from
the back she was in an all black
ensemble and had her hoodie up over her
head
the
reality star security team followed
closely behind in a black range rover
telling the ambulance ambulance as they
arrived at the hospital both vehicles
were apparently entered through the
wrong area and were redirected by
hospital personnel to a different
entrance
right after the story made headlines uh
travis's 16 year old daughter posted
please send your prayers and also in the
midst of this uh medical emergency
travis tweeted god save me at 10 45 a.m
it also is worth noting it is the name
of his song with machine gun yeah and i
thought it was before but the timing is
eerie i thought it was before he was
photographed it was 10 45 a.m
and i think well then it was the
afternoon he was rushed okay so maybe
it's just like weird coincidence yeah um
and then he was i think supposed to
perform with
mgk and his son landon stepped in wow
which is cool obviously not under these
circumstances and they haven't told us
like what's going on i just feel like if
you go to the hospital in an ambulance
like there's something really bad like
yeah because a lot of people like if you
go to the hospital like someone can
drive you and i think obviously not for
the kardashians but most people don't go
to the hospital in an ambulance because
it's so expensive but like if you're in
an ambulance that's like dire need of
care immediately yeah so i'm like really
concerned me too and obviously like they
don't know what's an explanation like
medical privacy is a thing but like i'm
beyond curious like what's going on of
course i agree curious respect their
privacy yeah i hope he's okay like
hopefully it's just you know appendix
also like uh alabama saying please send
your prayers cry emoji is like really
scary yeah
i wonder what's going on you think it
has anything to do with his arm if his
arm was like up in the photographs even
though that could mean nothing i don't
think so it looks like he like it looks
like an okay arm yeah
i don't know i don't know what like
maybe they make you keep your arms up
right but they're like so healthy you
know like the cleanses and they're vegan
right so i wonder yeah sending prayers
truly that's so scary yeah courtney must
be bugging i feel like she doesn't do
well under like in a crisis you think
yeah
yeah i could see that
something you never know until you're
tested yeah yeah that's true actually do
you think i think you do well in a
crisis i'm like full [ __ ] panic the
world is burning yeah
shred the files like um
i am the worst in a panic situation if
the if the crisis is about me
if it's about someone else i think i'm
extremely rational honestly
i think i'm because i don't care i'm
really good in the crisis one because
that's just like my nature but two i
don't realize something's a big deal
until way after it happens yeah whether
it's good or bad you know
yes i agree with that so that way so i
see something i'm like okay and then
it's like later i'm like girl yeah no
i'll see something and always think it's
a bigger deal than it is oh yeah like a
drama queen yeah like
yeah that's
you know who the worst person in a
crisis is ben
worst person in a crisis like you think
i'm bad he's so dramatic like let's go
to the greatest lengths like the le the
thing you would do is the last resort
he's like yeah let's do it first he's
just not good in a crisis so funny yeah
and he should be because he's the oldest
kid in his family and like
you have to have like a sense of like
calm and you know like olivia's very
olivia's a little drama yeah olivia's
not drama but olivia just like talks in
hyperbole exclusively yeah yeah and
she'll admit that to you yeah
but i wouldn't say like no and some
olivia's someone that you want to go to
like when you have to clean up your mess
yeah like she'll help you like she'll
get the shovel and she'll help you you
bury the body and she'll never say a
word about it no she will be very
exaggerated yeah she was like so we were
in this forest yeah it was literally a
thousand degrees we had to watch 200
meters yes
olivia loves to exaggerate with like
numbers yeah 200 packs of gum
that's what i was just gonna say can you
remind me of that story that's by the
way so in our family olivia probably
hates it but we're always saying like
she's an exaggerator and it started with
this one story it's just like the story
was emblematic of how she exaggerates i
don't remember the details but loosely i
remember that like we were on vacation
we were on vacation we were going to
walgreens yeah we were old enough to
like go to the pharmacy for for
ourselves and we bought like what we
wanted maybe you bought a pack of gum
and i bought a pack of gum and somehow
when we got home like we were all
fighting and she was like well you guys
were the ones who needed to go and buy
200 packs of and she ratted us out like
yeah she was like they literally about
200 pecks again we're like what
and back like as the oldest like
olivia's word is gospel right like we
could fight and argue and have proof
look there's just two packs it doesn't
matter because olivia is the oldest as
if we chewed 190 on the way home
so it's like olivia's word is gospel and
like it was so frustrating as a kid
because like you can't argue because
olivia's the oldest when we went to the
walgreens she was in charge right
so maybe like we didn't get something
that we needed to get because we spent
the money buying 200 pictures of gum
like oh my god i totally forgot about
that
and she [ __ ] ratted us out like we
didn't even do anything we just wanted
gum yeah
200 packs though yeah i could
i can't that's so old she's going to
kill us
kill us
okay
our next story the ships are sinking you
guys
and anna kendrick and bill hader have
broken up we should add them to our list
maybe not anna kendrick but bill hater
for sure yeah bill hater for sure and
anna kendrick who did she use today you
know who she always reminds me of
who
rachel kat dennings
oh she kept tending to used to date josh
groban that's why you love kat
add josh groban to the list kat jennings
doesn't think of anyone more eligible
yeah dennis followed me on instagram
even though we've like had dm'd a couple
times like exchanging like replies i
thought it was like incredibly hurtful
damn you see if she ever i mean i
followed her once i realized it i
followed her back immediately what about
josh groban and chloe carter i know you
were gonna say that that to me like i
think i would could retire yeah i could
retire peacefully knowing that khloe
kardashian was sleeping in the arms of
josh groban
or bill hader he's like a funny guy
i think it's age-appropriate yeah i
could see him like vibing with the
kardashians i could see like now that
kim is with p like
the s
yeah like chloe being open to someone
funny of that nature yeah and bill
coming across her desk yeah honestly
even though i'm not like an anna
kendrick gurley i did think this was
like a nice couple because they were
like really low-key and quiet and
they've kind of been together for a
while
um so those are the types of
relationships you don't really expect to
break up yeah these to me like if you
had told me they've been married for 20
years i would have been like yeah i knew
that yeah but he also briefly dated
rachel bilson and i missed them already
that was like an iconic and you know i
didn't just didn't see for bill hader
like becoming like this bachelor man
about town no i could see it because in
train rides yeah he was everything i
think he owes all of his like a-list
star relationships to amy schumer
because we can i think we can all agree
that we were not looking at bill hader
like that until his role in train wreck
wrecks 135
we were just like plus 200 packs
we were just like that funny guy from
snl he's in some of our favorite films
and shows but we are now seeing him in a
whole new light and it's it started the
second i walked out of the theater
watching train wreck yeah and that's on
telling the truth
i'm sad for him and anna though
i'm not going to remember this because i
barely remember that they were together
and announced that they were together i
was like wait he broke up with rachel
bilson and when he announced he was with
the rachel bilson i was like wait he's
dating rachel wilson yeah no it's
shocking it's really shocking to keep
all of this apart but if he were to date
chloe i would never forget it never ever
forget or josh corbin
are you ready for our next story only if
it's a story that's brought to you by
caraway homes non-toxic cookware and
bakeware collections so that you can
make healthier cooking a piece of cake
the non-toxic kitchen wears are all
designed for the modern home and they
feature a chemical-free ceramic coating
so food can be prepped with peace of
mind that no hard-to-pronounce compound
is going to leach into your healthy
ingredients all of the sets come
equipped with easy access storage
solutions so that no stacking is
required the cookware set which is
modern and chemical free iteration of
the traditional 16 piece set
is boiled down to just the essentials
which is so like who the [ __ ] needs 16
pieces you need a frying pan a saute pan
a sauce pan and a dutch oven that's all
you need i have the four piece first of
all it's so cute i got it in pink and it
just like looks good in my gorgeous in
my home and it really is like so you're
like it's just a pan it's really so much
better and so different than like all
the crappy pans i have in my drawers
it's not like other pants it's not it's
so easy to clean it's so easy to clean
it doesn't scratch nearly as easily as
like some of the other ones i have in my
cabinets
they also have a bakeware set which is
an assortment of non-toxic baking
essentials that every modern kitchen
needs so you can get to baking without
any of the baths they're super well
loved they have tons of great reviews
their naturally slick surface means
minimal oil or butter for a slide off
the pan egg and again they're non-toxic
and they have no hard to pronounce
chemicals like pfas ptfe pfao oh my god
tfo
um
so if you want to check out caraway
homes non-toxic cookware visit
carawayhome.com
tmt take advantage of this limited time
offer for 10
off your next purchase the deal is
exclusive for our listeners so visit
carawayhome.com
tmt or use code tmt at checkout caraway
non-toxic cookware made modern and
that's tmt as in the morning toast duh
get your enlaps yeah get your [ __ ]
ass up and cook yeah and you shouldn't
have to tell people this is a camera pro
situation 100
100 stop letting your food stick on your
path you know before i released my
grammy winning song 100 we had like a
few different iterations of
of the chorus yeah what was one of them
and sometimes when i say 100 i say it
like the old chorus it was supposed to
be like 100
tell the dj that i'm here tonight kind
of sounds good wait
that's really good yeah so when i say
hundred percent that's from like my old
one of the demos you know as they say in
the industry it must be so hard for you
artists to keep apart the final version
no there's sometimes like i think of my
old demo for um toast it's stunk i'm so
glad we didn't go that it was like how
does that song start hannah down we
gonna have a good time it's been a while
i've been waiting and it was that's
hundred percent oh [ __ ] wait how does
the verse of toast start how many time
we gonna have a good time a thousand
hands up to this can't let it fade so it
was supposed to be like can't let it
fade we got a sparkle in our eyes
i'm counting down until we start we're
renegades we come to play put that until
you choose play hard release demos
yeah because it sounds good when i sing
it but i have like videos from a studio
and it was like turn
damn but you won't know until you get in
the studio you know us musicians know
that obviously that's why we have to get
in the studio if i were to put out an
album on spotify i would just go to show
you anyone can do anything anything is
possible if you just believe no and you
work really hard and force people to
listen to your voice no of course like
we would once we got you in the studio
like we would show you like how to sing
the right pitch in the right key and
then like a little auto-tune
star star
i love that okay our next story speaking
of stars
lizzo teaches james corden about dan
time dance on carpool karaoke and shares
how beyonce inspired her career so last
week claudia was saying that james
corden was teasing the biggest artist on
the world was going to be in karaoke
carpool county the biggest artist in
music right now and i and she thought it
was going to be taylor swift and i said
no who did i say it was going to be
i feel like i guess like dojo cat oh
yeah and it's lizzo and i like we were
standing by what i said which was like
he was being extremely literal yeah in
music right now so obviously i'm
disappointed it wasn't taylor but i'd
love to just see lizzy doing her thing
she got a flute and she was just like
being flutiered that's cute yeah
my her fluting abilities are one of my
favorite things about her yeah no it's
really cool and it definitely sets her
apart and she's so good at it and you
know i feel like she's just making like
band geeks everywhere
even though i'm not saying like if
you're in a band you're a geek it's just
like a trope leave me alone um and i
feel like james gordon hasn't done
karaoke carpool karaoke in a while at
first it was like strictly legends and
then he got like a little desperate it
was like throwing like random people in
there who like i didn't think had
reached the mark yet and then he like
stopped doing it yeah
they needed a break yeah but taylor's
never done it beyonce's never done it
adele has done it celine dion has done
it
who else
like legends wise pink has done it
i think so
selena gomez has miley yeah her whole
family had a show on apple tv yeah that
doesn't count i'm talking about the
james corden version she definitely did
yeah pink did carpool karaoke has kelly
clarkson
for sure
i need to watch that if she did you know
the so kanye did airplane carry oh that
was so good madonna you know the super
bowl should go through the youtube
playlist of who's been on carpool
karaoke to see who's like big enough
for the halftime show kelly's been on
carpool karaoke okay good it should have
been carpool kelly arie has been ari yes
selena the jonas brothers with them and
then they started doing like oh you're
not famous enough to be a legend let's
put two like demi lovato and the jonas
brothers like the super bowl yeah but
like we need taylor we need beyonce
yeah katy perry
i'm sure she has yeah
and then we need to move on yeah
yeah yeah she's done it so he's like
really hit all of that maybe that's why
he hasn't done it because like he's ran
out of legends but i'm glad lizzo did
one it's like a badge of honor i feel
like it officially means like you have
staying power in the industry you know
and she looked great she's saying great
i feel like every time i learn more
about lizzo like not from her music but
like on a conversational level i like
like what i say yeah she's like funny
and like self-deprecating and like good
sense of humor for sure yeah and her
music is great so great yeah
wait a minute
i'm anita sentimental man or woman to
pump me up feeling fussy walking in my
valencia valencia is so funny you know
it's like a tic tac thing to put like us
see
like when you do something really good
people like wow zendaya put her holes in
dussy in this oh in this
euphoria like when somebody does a
really good job it's like they put their
whole
jackie essie into like your whole [ __ ]
into something messy i like that jack
cussy i don't know what it would be no i
like jackie
yeah and so i like that she and she also
loves tick tock fellow tik tok stand so
she's constantly you know using
tick-tock language in everyday life
love it would you love to see you love
to see are you ready for our fifth and
final story it's the final story
[Music]
and that's a magic number
fifth and final story sorry for partying
airbnb makes its party ban permanent
airbnb announced a global temporary ban
on parties and events nearly two years
ago now the home sharing company is
putting the ban in place permanently
airbnb will continue to bar disruptive
parties and events including open invite
gatherings party houses which people
book for a large event for one night
will also stay banned
don't you feel like this should be up to
the home owner yeah because let's say of
course like you know if you have a super
nice house you want families to come you
don't want people like trashing and i
get that and parties mean mess but i
think some people would be okay with
like having their customers pay a
premium to rent the house for one night
throw a party that includes like
cleaning fees they pay a little bit more
um i don't know why
like airbnb wants to speak on behalf of
all of their
right and also
maybe they just like like the b and b
format but like you should be able to
like book an airbnb for one night and
like have your wedding there you know
yeah that's a whole other business model
for them there should be airbnb biz like
corporate retreats yeah yeah that's like
it's like so weird it's kind of like on
cameo you can book a cameo as a business
but everyone has a personal rate and a
business rate because you'd obviously
pay more to be like i love lacroix it's
delicious and bubbly interesting yeah so
like if if somebody wants to do it as
like an official venue with like a party
as like a venue for a party venue for a
corporate retreat venue for family
reunion like no actually family reunion
could go in the personal one but there
should be like
like the the homeowners should have the
option to make more money if they want
to also what constitutes a party you
know right like dinner party like oh i'm
renting an airbnb um
three couples are coming over for dinner
you know yeah how many people is a party
what level of noise is a party i think
more than 20 people is a party what if
you had like 25 people
and it's a silent disco
that sounds so fun what if you have 30
people it's a silent disco of sober
people
no that's definitely interesting
i just feel like it should be up to like
so many people make their living
exclusively on airbnb and i just don't
think airbnb should be restricting how
homeowners want to use their house like
if they're if the owner's up to it yeah
like you have to take okay let's say the
house is let's say a house is 500 a
night but if you want to throw a party
it's fifteen hundred dollars and you owe
me a three thousand dollar deposit just
in case you break stuff um and a
cleaning fee like what homeowner
wouldn't want that like the option but
the option but wouldn't most people just
like pretend to try and get away with
having a party and paying lesser rate
like yes but that's [ __ ] up like
that's not cool no
no
airbnb is a crazy concept and they're
always like making crazy rules you know
like they're very um
heavy-handed in their management yeah
but just this idea that like people are
renting out their homes but the thing is
with airbnb it's usually not people's
primary homes no but some a lot of
people like sometimes like
it's both yeah but i think like the the
the way that a lot of people turn it
into like a full-fledged business is by
renting out properties that they don't
live in yeah and have no intention of
everything right like when you go to
nashville you really see like how airbnb
has taken over so much of like the real
estate economy every [ __ ] house
townhouse condo is like a full flip no
one lives there permanently and they
make huge income every year just by
renting it out like bachelorette parties
it's very cool visitors and it's changed
like now there's also like airbnb for
cars you know is there it's called turo
oh but it's not airbnb no no no but it's
like you know they need a car for three
days it's like uber for blank like it
became its own industry yeah
i think it's great i just think like
and maybe they're doing this to protect
the homeowners but i just think like
give people the option yeah
and they really should get into like
venues don't be a narc they should get
into like
business like there should be two yes
but sometimes it's like you could like
i'd learn on shark tank like you can't
do everything and you need to focus on
your business model and like also being
you know a wedding planning destination
it's
too much they also recently went public
so like they're obviously doing
something right yeah so like who the
[ __ ] am i to say with my private company
you know
very private we're so proud so private
um
to devon to dear toasters that was a
fast five let's please um so we've got
three great submissions that are brought
to you by the green pet shop if you're
like us and you talk about your pets as
if they're human beings or treat them as
your children hashtag larp listen up
summer's officially here and the risks
of heat stroke in our pets in hot humid
weather are treacherous and very real so
the green pet shop's patented and
award-winning cool pet pad is a
self-activated gel cooling mat that
keeps your pet cool for hours it's
pressure activated so once your dog or
cat lays on the pad they'll start to
feel the cooling effects instantly the
mats are eco-friendly and there's no
water refrigeration or electricity
required you just grab and go so like if
you're spending a lot of time outside
this summer and your dog's just like
following you around there's no harm in
just leaving the pad out because
obviously i think people are more than
likely to worry about their pets in the
cold but dogs can get overheated
especially their paw pads on concrete so
just have a nice safe space for them to
relax like bruno mags magnolia and theo
like they need that these pads are bryce
tested strice approved also they also
just have a lot of great products at the
green pet shop
you can add fashion to your order with a
pink or gray cover for your cooling mat
and a pack of pui vuitton eco waste bags
puiviton are the thickest strongest and
most stylish eco waste bags on the
market they're made from cornstarch
instead of plastic so you and your dog
are going to be a part of protecting the
planet
to shop the cool pet pad and the
puiviton eco waste bags use code toast
for 20 off at thegreenpetshop.com
that's code toast at thegreenpetshop.com
all right dear toasters our advice
segment we do it every wednesday and if
you want to submit it's dear toasters at
gmail.com we will always keep your name
anonymous do not worry about that um if
you want to submit please do just always
try and keep it brief not like brief
like just give us a need to know details
because if you're writing a whole
megillah even if it's the craziest thing
like we can't read it on the show so if
you've submitted and we haven't read it
yet it might be because yours is too
long or
it just sucks but
just dear toasters at gmail.com we we
need some fresh submissions okay i need
to put my thinking cap on for this first
one here's a little bit of that here's a
little bit of background my friend's dad
walked out on her mom six years ago
since then my friend's mom has dated
around and she recently fell in love
again and married her second husband in
june 2021 after they'd been dating for
about a year and a half okay i've spent
time with my friend her mom and her new
husband gone out to dinner hung out at
their house this past weekend i was back
in my hometown for the weekend and i oh
sorry this was also written by a man a
gay man i just think because we're used
to straight women
so this past weekend i was back in my
hometown and i opened up my grinder as i
usually do
an older man message me my grinder
profile does not show my face so people
don't know who exactly they're talking
to just a 26 year old with nice abs lol
so i'm scrolling and an anonymous older
man messages me and says are you into
older question mark wanna play today
question mark his profile only showed
his smile but it looked vaguely familiar
and i had a hunch of who it may be so
even though i had no interest in meeting
up with him i replied yeah do you have a
face pick sure enough it's him my
friend's new stepdad my friend is out of
the country at a wedding with her mom
right now so it makes complete sense
that this would be an opportune time for
him to cheat now i'm struggling to
decide if i should tell my friend or her
mom i don't want my friend to have to
bear that burden after recently having
her parents getting divorced and i also
don't want to spoil my friend's mom's
happiness after all they could have some
sort of open arrangement that is frankly
none of my business what should i do if
anything at all i promise to provide
updates if there are any
so i think
i don't know there's a few
the thing is like
honestly i'm torn i do think like it's
very possible that they have an open
like thing it's also very possible that
like her husband's gay and cheating on
her like yeah and that's a real reality
and i do think like and i agree with you
like telling your friend is like just
passing the burden on to her yeah
honestly like if you're like a
i don't know gay men have a way of like
telling you straight
in a way that's like non-offensive and i
could see a way like of you if you're
close with her mom just like going
straight to her
and being like listen i just want you to
know no judgment this is what i found we
never have to talk about it ever again
but i couldn't like really sleep at
night if i didn't just show this to you
and then we're done we'll never talk
about it i swear to god nothing will
change yeah
i think that's a good way i don't think
you should tell your friend
i guess that's true
i think that's a good idea right
and i do feel like you know women
straight women really feel like they can
trust gay men there's like this unspoken
bond and allyship so i do feel like if
you went and went up to her and they had
some sort of arrangement and you were
like i don't know what this is i promise
i'll never bring it up again she would
trust you to like not tell her daughter
and like really keep it between and not
make things weird yeah i like that
better than telling the daughter and
making it her problem because then also
like the daughter will eventually tell
her mom and like her mom whatever her
mom chooses to do like if she decides to
stay with him or maybe this was you know
something that she knew about like
she'll always know that her daughter
knows and like yeah and
telling the daughter doesn't fix
anything it just adds up another person
to the mix
and then if the daughter then tells her
mom her mom will feel embarrassed that
like her daughter's friend has known for
a few months but like if this were you
like in practice in practice let me
theory in in practice i would
not do a thing
you know yeah let me think of like a
friend of mine whose parents i know i
would make myself forget it you would go
to a friend's parent
and tell them that they're part like no
i would just be like they're close
i would just
pretend like i never saw it i know but
it's so big in practice but in theory i
like what you're saying it's so big like
not only is he cheating but he might be
gay like it's
it's such a big secret to keep
it's really tough it's a horrible
situation to be in yeah i think
if if you think the right thing is to
not do anything then don't do anything
but if you do feel like you want to do
something i'm not saying it's the right
thing tonight i'm not saying i'm saying
to the person who wrote in yeah no but
i'm not saying i would do nothing
because it's the right thing to do
because i'm like
if i would live with that like i would
be like shaking in my boots like trying
to tell her you know this might be a
situation where an anonymous letter um
comes into play you know the first night
at bed ron put his
head between a cocktail waitress's
breasts right
just even though that makes the whole
situation more creepy and right because
then it's also she has to figure out her
relationship but then also who's a
stranger
a stranger knows yeah no that's scary
that's scarier either do nothing or go
direct to the mom yeah depending on your
personality like if you're have that
sort of a relationship if you you know
are very
courageous yeah
but that's the thing with grinder
culture i think um
you know most i would say like 9 out of
10 people on grindr don't have their
faces in it because it's really just
like an app for physical connection
um and sometimes you will run into
someone you know
and like i have gay friends who've told
me about it and like it's literally the
worst thing in the world especially if
you're newly out a lot of people use the
app to experiment and since you don't
have to share your face it's like you're
not really you know there's no risk um
but then if you like message someone and
it's always people in your area and then
you end up messaging someone who you
know or like like maybe like your cousin
like can it can get really murky yeah
because people don't say their names or
their faces they just have user names
and like usually the chin down and
usually like a sexy abs pick
so this is the the dark side of grinder
that they don't tell you about yeah so
we've given you two options you know
yourself and you know this woman and
do what you think is best but i'm sorry
that this is that this burden has fallen
into your lap yeah but i do feel like
you're equipped to handle it like i
really do i think so too i don't know
why you want like you're speaking like
very matter-of-factly no end because
like not like emotion like just what do
i do i think if it was like one of the
girls
girlfriends
it would be a totally different
situation but the fact that he's like a
gay guy just makes me think like the mom
will be more open to what he's saying do
you know what i mean yeah i don't know
why i just feel like that's the case
yeah all right next up hey jackson
claude iconic duo
hey i added the iconic duo it wasn't
written
i was going to be like she sounds
wonderful
how you doing i'm an english toaster in
desperate need of advice
kurdish camper okay
a few weeks ago my boyfriend went on
vacation with his friends to portugal
all the boys that went have girlfriends
were a big group of friends today my
boyfriend let it slip one night that
they went to a strip club and one of the
boys maverick got a hand job and a
shower from a stripper first of all ew
second all what do i do with this
information do i tell maverick's
girlfriend the boy my boyfriend has
sworn me to secrecy but i just don't
know whether i have a duty to tell her
although i'm also aware that if i do
tell her then it would literally ruin
her life any advice you could provide
would be greatly appreciated oh my god
you guys have really had me stumped
today yeah that's a tough thing you know
i did go through something similar but
it was like with a
couple that like i don't know i went
through something similar to with a
couple that i like i was talking about i
had no personal stake in the matter yeah
i was talking to a friend of mine who
went on a bachelor party and he was
telling me like one of the guys there
who was engaged like did something bad
but like i don't know these people so
like i just have this information but
i'll never like do anything about it
because i don't even know these people
literally sane so
but imagine if you were really close to
the situation and the couple
if i was really
your boyfriend put you in a horrible
position yeah and i love him for being
honest with you sounds like you guys
have a great relationship no i don't
like that he told you because why do you
need to know and it makes me feel like
not to like you know
cast doubt but it just like makes me
feel like he told you this thing about
him about this other guy because like to
folk get your focus on that and like
maybe he did something okay let's not
make it more this is what i'm feeling
like because like why throw fred under
the bus maverick sorry yeah no i really
don't know what to do here like
i i would need to know more about your
friendship with this girl yeah but you
know what and like there sounds like a
time for an anonymous letter oh so there
are showers at the strip club that you
can that's what i'm confused about for
sure unless like they took a stripper
back that's that's different than like
getting handsy at the strip club yeah
but still like getting handsy at the
strip club is also different than a
[ __ ] hand job like
everyone gets handsy at a strip club
right is that where you're actually
that's not what you're supposed to do
but like you always cross a line yeah
when you go to a strip club no but like
to adjust
strip club tings out of the strip club
is another line oh yeah yeah but even
like physical skin-to-skin contact with
an
orifice
is also crossing a line yeah and it's
like you can't get a pay to get a hand
job at a strip club right i mean it
depends on the type of strip club but
like i think you probably can but isn't
that illegal well first of all they were
in portugal so i don't know the laws
but like yeah no a lot of strip clubs
like you know in the back have you know
blurred lines yeah yeah yeah like if you
want to make an extra so
i would say if it was in the back
maybe
don't tell her but if they left together
and took a shower and like
that's that's a little more serious
don't you think like yeah but i still
think the hand job in the back is bad
but couldn't you chalk it up to like
bachelor party tings not your business i
feel like strat club first
party
second of all um bachelor party gone
wild is like
getting a lap dance like maybe putting
your hands like
on her boob for a second like let me ask
you a question if ben got if you found
out that he got a hand job at a strip
club
i would
burn the place down
like ejaculating like [ __ ] literally i
could do that you could do that why do
you have to have some random girl do it
yeah in the shower that's unacceptable
would it make it worse if they went back
to the hotel and it happened of course
that's what i'm saying because you have
all this time like on the cab ride up
the elevator like i think there's a
difference between getting carried away
at the strip club
versus taking it home with you but i
don't think getting a hand job is
considered getting carried away i think
it's further than that i think it's
really carried away no i think it's
cheating
so would you want to know
yeah but the thing about me is like i
don't if this if i was this girl in this
situation like i don't feel bad about
like doing the right thing and pissing
off like a guy like you literally [ __ ]
up it's not about pissing off that guy
it's about disrupting the it's about
disrupting her equilibrium and getting
your boyfriend in trouble
yeah but it's like
i don't know but maybe this is just the
tip of the iceberg you know yeah if
you're so easily carried away on a boys
trip it's like not gonna be hard for you
to cheat again or that doesn't mean you
haven't done it before yeah yeah yeah i
think you should tell her but like
before you do like you have to get her
solemn swear to tude that you won't tell
him that you heard from
this girl because then that gets her
boyfriend in trouble then her boyfriend
looks like a loser like you're not like
gonna be like bro code like so this is a
mess if there's a way you can guarantee
the girl won't rat you out i do think
you should tell her
okay
or an anonymous note no because then she
also has to worry about who knows this
is a um
this is the case for form spring
remember that anonymous forum when like
you used to have in high school and i
was like ask me anything people be like
you're fat i'm like why the [ __ ] did i
put this up yeah form spring tell her be
like we should get back into form spring
girly
and then right be like the first one
like
when your boyfriend went to portugal he
got a hand job from a stripper in the
back of a shower yeah unclear where the
shower was sometimes form spring is the
only answer and i mean that i'm sorry we
couldn't be more helpful i thought it
was helpful i think you should tell her
but like make sure you don't get your
boyfriend in trouble because then he's
like gonna hate you and like
his friends will think he's a loser
next step and the final one but maybe
the friends are illusory group of
friends they need to disband because
they're going to portugal and getting
hand-drawn right and like this is the
sign that like maybe you and they are
growing apart and their girl have
girlfriends yet they're not doing a
couple's trip but it was also no one's
bachelor party right
right like if you're going to a strip
club on a bachelor party that's more
understandable but like just a trip with
your friends to go to a straight club no
i'm sorry strip clubs for people in
relationships are extenuating
circumstances like a bachelor party
all right final one hey girlies i've
been listening for about a year now and
i love your podcast and i need some
advice about my current boyfriend we've
been doing long distance for three years
i noticed he was following some random
girls on instagram i asked him if he was
friends with these girls and he said no
he was not so of course i said so why
are you adding them on instagram he then
proceeded to say i was controlling since
i was checking his instagram followers i
just think in a committed relationship
you shouldn't feel the need to look at
and follow random girls that you don't
know do you guys think i'm justified or
am i actually crazy lol thank you are
they famous girls no it sounds like
random girls like with 300 followers and
he's one of them and i like how you
write are you do you girls think i'm
justified or am i actually crazy because
you are fully being gaslit like he's
making you think this is like a crazy
thing for you to think when it's
completely rational yeah no i think
following like instagram thoughts is
just like fine and something we all have
to accept unfortunately yeah but
following
girls the difference is like the
instagram uh
model or you know bikini model whatever
it's never going to see your husband
notice him whatever but like when a girl
who's not who doesn't have a big
following like sees this guy it's like
he has visibility yeah with her and i
think that is weird it's very weird and
honestly what i find even weirder than
the fact that he follows these girls was
his reaction to your question like yeah
it's full gas lighting you're
controlling like this guy sounds like a
walking [ __ ] red flag like i really
think you gotta go honestly yeah i think
that's really weird i've never had to
think about like following random
lay people yeah but it's weird like he
could dm her and like start a
relationship and he's making you feel
like you're being unreasonable and crazy
and controlling and you're literally not
and that's just like the beginning of
the mind games honestly i don't see this
ending well i think you should get out i
know that's like not the answer you were
looking for he's giving extreme takes
and i'm feeling very conflicted today
sometimes like people show you who they
are and like you have to believe them
like that's a crazy [ __ ] response and
like even the way she was writing to us
like she thinks she might be acting
crazy you're not he's literally
gaslighting you yeah goodbye goodbye
deuces
thank you for writing in though sorry
about the three years and thank you to
everyone who wrote in again that's
deartoasters gmail.com every wednesday
so if you didn't get read this week
there's always next and it's a long
distance relationship so if these are
like local girls that he's following who
he has the
ability to
get in touch with like it's nefarious
yeah
this is not it
at all
um but that was it because that was our
show but it's not over yet because if
you're listening as a podcast jill's are
an interview coming up right now and if
you're watching on youtube head over to
the previous video on our channel the
jill interview lives
enjoy this interview with jill we love
you guys bye
[Music]
you